nearly a million people canceled their
subscription streaming giant Netflix
suffered its biggest stock loss for most
people to pay for all of the streaming
services that's no secret that Netflix
is getting destroyed they've started
losing subscribers for the first time
their stock has crashed as much as 76
and they're the fifth worst performing
stock in the S P 500 this is quite a
turn of events from the 2010s when
Netflix was literally the best
performing stock on the market growing a
mind-boggling 40x this Sudden Change in
performance doesn't really surprise me
at all that much every stock has Raging
Bull markets and bear markets and given
the overall macroeconomic situation it's
not crazy that a high-flying stock like
Netflix has cooled down substantially
but what is surprising to me is the
Public's reaction to sets off
historically the everyday Personnel
wasn't even aware of the financial or
economical state of such companies but
thanks to social media the average
person has well aware of Netflix's
situation and they're not only happy
about it but it almost seems like
they're rooting for it what is Netflix
doing in Fang they're about to fall
Netflix is going to get dropped from the
Fang acronym soon if Netflix goes out of
business I hope I get my money back LOL
Netflix sucks and it's also run by
satanists aside from such comments on
YouTube there are entire threads on
Reddit that are dedicated to trashing on
Netflix it appears that the public
sentiments surrounding Netflix is almost
as bad as the public sentiment
surrounding Amazon or big Banks unlike
big Banks though Netflix was a community
favorite not too long ago so why does
everyone suddenly despise Netflix
foreign
critiques that people make up on Netflix
is that their library of content just
isn't that good anymore but much of this
was completely out of their control when
licensors like Disney and the Paramount
decide to start their own streaming
services and make their content
exclusive to their own platforms there's
really not much that Netflix can really
do not to mention it even after losing
some key Partners Netflix objectively
has one of the largest streaming
libraries in the world as of April 2022
Netflix has 17 000 titles streaming
globally now you might be saying that
just because they have so many titles
does not mean that they're actually
worth watching and while that is true I
would argue that Netflix has more shows
and movies that are worth watching than
any other streaming service in terms of
shows they've got Breaking Bad Better
Call Saul money Heist stranger things
great game at manifest peaky blinders
the 100 the Umbrella Academy the Queen's
Gambit Cobra Kai and the BoJack Horseman
just to name a few they've also got
plenty of dependent thought-provoking
documentaries like Icarus the Ted Bundy
tapes athlete a dirty money the greatest
events of World War II in color and
downfall of the case against Boeing it's
also not uncommon to find some of the
most iconic movies of all time make the
round through Netflix like The Titanic
Gladiator Inception Interstellar the
James Bond movies and so much more so
objectively speaking while not all
content on Netflix is top of the line
there are hundreds of shows and movies
and documentaries that are worth
watching this is not something that you
can say about any other streaming
service whether it be Disney Plus or HBO
Max they use usually only have a handful
or maybe a dozen TV shows and movies
that people really want to watch
with Disney Plus for example I know so
many people who got the subscription
just so they can watch the Mandalorian
aside from already having a massive
library of content Netflix hasn't been
shy when it comes to investing into wall
performing Originals a perfect example
of this was their budget for season 4 of
stranger things each episode of Season 4
costs Netflix 30 million dollars with a
total of 9 episodes Netflix literally
spent 270 million dollars on season 4.
that's literally more than the budget of
Avatar 2. it also comes out to over five
thousand seven hundred dollars per
second of screen time and it's not just
stranger things either Netflix spent 9
million dollars per episode for since 8
10 million dollars per episode for The
Witcher 11 million dollars per episode
for the get down and the 13 million
dollars per episode for the crown so
Netflix's Content Library is not a
garbage like mini claim objectively
speaking it's actually the best in the
world and if you don't believe me just
take a look at this study the study
asked 4 000 U.S adults the following
question if you could only keep one
streaming service which one would it be
unsurprisingly Netflix won by a
landslide garnering 41 of the vote Hulu
came in second place at 21 and HBO Max
came in at 13 but if it's not the
content that's giving Netflix a bad rep
what is
after reading through dozens of Reddit
threads and hundreds of YouTube comments
I came to realize that while people
often blame Netflix's content that's
usually not the root of their
frustration by far the biggest source of
frustration seems to be Netflix's
constantly increasing subscription fees
the lowest tier itself costs 10 per
month but no one actually wants this
tier because you can't even stream in HD
you literally have to stream in 480p
which is completely unacceptable in 2022
even the crappiest smartphones on the
market have a higher resolution than
480p so this tier does not suit the
needs of anyone and the only reason
anyone gets this tier is to save money
realistically people need to at least
spring for the standard tier to enjoy
these shows and movies in a modern
resolution but that comes in at 15.50
per month or 186 dollars per year to
make things worse more people have 4K
TVs than ever before thanks to how cheap
they've gotten you can literally get get
an 85 inch 4K TV for the same price as
an iPhone 14 pro Max and ends not from
RCA or Hitachi either it's literally
from Samsung but while high quality 4K
TVs are more accessible than ever it
seems like Netflix's 4K streaming option
is more inaccessible than ever coming in
at 20 per month in just five years your
streaming subscription itself will end
up costing more than your TV Netflix is
well aware of this and one of their
proposed Solutions is introducing a
cheaper Tierra deck comes with ads but
it seems like this proposal has simply
backfired on Netflix to many it this
move simply comes off as greedy and
completely unnecessary Netflix
increasing their prices is nothing new
though this has been an ongoing
phenomenon for nearly a decade but
historically no one really cared thanks
to Shared accounts if you were sharing
your premium Netflix account with four
other people a price increase from 15
per month to 20 per month doesn't really
bother you
before you were paying three dollars a
month and now you're paying four dollars
per month Netflix has always been aware
of this but they didn't really care
because their subscriber numbers were
growing so fast cracking down on people
sharing passwords was simply not a top
priority historically but with
subscriptions starting to stagnate
Netflix has finally cracked down Netflix
has started charging people a fee if
their account is consistently being used
in more than one household so more and
more people have been forced to just get
an account themselves which means that
their monthly fee jumps from like three
or four dollars per month to 20 per
month on an annual basis that's
literally a price hike of two hundred
dollars I mean honestly I don't think
it's fair to just blame Netflix for this
just because they turned a blind eye to
password sharing in the past does not
mean that cracking down on password
sharing is unreasonable nonetheless it's
also not surprising that so many people
are salty about it
foreign
per month is not that bad and I agree
it's not that bad but it's not the
Netflix fee alone that's triggering
people the problem is that you can't
just have Netflix if you want to
actually enjoy all of the most popular
shows and movies even though Netflix
still has the most diverse and desirable
catalog there are several TV shows and
movies that are only available on other
platforms this wasn't that big of a
problem when there were only two or
three prominent streaming services but
now what everyone seems to have their
own Services you've got Netflix Hulu HBO
Max Disney plus Prime video Paramount
plus Discovery plus and Apple tv even if
you just choose the top 5 streaming
services this adds up very quickly
especially if you get the top tier
option for each one Netflix is 20 per
month Hulu is 13 per month HBO Max is 15
per month Disney plus is 80 per year and
Amazon Prime is 140 per year when you
add all these up you get 66 dollars per
month or 796 dollars per year and if you
feel like this sounds familiar that's
because this is how much satellite TV
providers like Dish and DirecTV charge
so in a sense it feels like we've come
full circle back to where we started the
reason that Netflix was so popular over
the last decade was because it was the
anti-thesis to regular television in
instead of being bloated with ads and
infomercials Netflix promised to offer
the best titles whenever and wherever
you wanted at a far cheaper price but
today it seems like streaming has just
become another version of Television the
only advantage that streaming services
have over traditional TV at this point
is that you don't have to deal with ads
for the same 60 to 70 price point but
with more random more streaming
platforms offering and supported
versions this will probably change
within the next several years honestly
this can only play out in two ways
either the streaming services introduce
ads to all of their plans or they're
gonna jack up the prices of their
ad-free plans even more and it's just a
matter of time until the streaming
services become indistinguishable from
regular television just with a modern
twist instead of having to watch on your
TV at a certain time you can watch on
any device at any time but that's pretty
much it one trick that still works is
the good old subscribe for a month and
cancel trick but streaming services are
well aware of this as well
this will probably just lead to more
shows being released at a pace of one
episode per week instead of the whole
season dropping it at the same time this
way they'll have a constant flow of
content the entire year and more people
will be enticed to stay subscribed and
at that point will truly be back to
Ground Zero as you would guess the vast
majority are not fans of the streaming
Evolution and the person they blame it
is Netflix obviously the situation is
not as simple as Netflix Being Greedy
but they've become an easy target so
when people see headlines that Netflix
is losing subscribers and that their
stock is performing worse than ever they
can't help but feel that Netflix got
what they deserved
foreign
despite all the doomsday headlines
Netflix simply isn't going anywhere so
far the entire subscriber loss is
equivalent to a measly 0.5 percent of
their total subscribers and that's with
every Factor working against them we've
got the Russian sanctions the post-covet
streaming Purge recession ludicrous
inflation and record high economic fears
if all of these factors are only leading
to Netflix losing 0.5 percent of their
subscribers this is clearly not that big
of a deal for Netflix long term this
isn't to say that Netflix is done losing
subscribers they have a quarterly report
coming out very soon and they may very
well report another loss and subscribers
for all I know they could post
subscriber losses for years to come but
eventually the economy will turn around
and the people will return to spending
more money freely and at that point I
can't see why Netflix won't just return
to posting phenomenal numbers we should
also mention that Netflix never stopped
posting phenomenal numbers in the first
place yes their subscriber numbers have
started to stagnate and their stock has
gotten destroyed but Netflix is still
posting record profits to this day and
as they continue to crack down on
password sharing it and invest heavily
into Originals I think this number will
only go up in the long term so while
public sentiments running Netflix is bad
and it'll probably only get worse I
don't think the same thing can be said
about Netflix stock especially under 200
per share but that's just what I think
do you think Netflix is being
unreasonable comment that down below
also drop a like if you're a fan of
stranger things and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community such
as for the video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one
foreign